The airplane is so aligned with your desire,...
...so if I want to go up a bit, I ask it to go up a bit and it goes up a bit.
I have never experienced such precision.
And you know, pilots love precision...
...so it's like getting in a formula one racing car, the drive of your life...
...and it goes fast, it goes high, and it goes slow, and it goes low...
...it does everything you want to do and it does it supremely well.
So, my first flight was in November of 2010...
...and I remember my very first impression of the airplane...
...was just how like the modeling and the simulation it was.
The airplane flies so much like the simulator...
...that I felt like I knew it immediately I jumped into the air.